[Music]
you feel the love for Chow when you're
out in the street walking around doing
your everyday business yeah actually I
get people yelling child catchphrases
all the time and actually the last time
I this actually I said this on the last
time I was here I was at an ATM and
middle-aged white dude in a convertible
staring at me for like the longest time
don't know why as he drives away he
yells
toodaloo mother story very well yes and
what happened and this is very true
honest to god three months three months
ago it was same ATM but different guy
different convertible as he drives away
after staring for a few minutes toodaloo
mother just kept doing that yeah and
what happened it was you know this guy I
felt like he was like you know what I
saw this bit on Conan I'm gonna do the
same bit again and I'm gonna do the same
ATM I'm gonna do the same thing and I'll
have to acknowledge me on Conan again
well you won Corvette guy in Calabasas
pat now he's watching
[Applause]